this is a production of Cornell
University
the gate now so the three research areas
that my lab encompasses here is focused
on crop nutrition of quality high
throughput phenotyping quantitative
genetics and genomics a large part of my
research is focused on maize which we
all love but it is a global starchy
staple crop and that would greatly
benefit from biofortification for a
development of nutrient dense grain why
I say this is when you focus on this map
here and this is an applet maize
consumption by mean percentage of daily
calories per capita you can see
countries in sub-saharan Africa that are
having to subsist very highly in terms
of their caloric intake from maize and
this orange country right here is Zambia
and in looking at the nutritional
profile of maize it often does not
provide adequate daily levels of
essential nutrients that we need to
survive as human beings and also feeding
to animals and the ones that we work on
in my research group is iron and zinc
and then Pro vitamin a vitamin E and the
vitamin complex but as you see here
maize is great in terms of vehicle for
getting carbohydrates out to animals and
human beings but is very deep opera in
terms of nutritional quality and so as
an approach you can have a plant bio
fortifying itself so harnessing the
genes and alleles that naturally occur
in the population or through
transgenesis or you could also
complement through a plant breeding with
chemical fortification dietary
diversification or are in the sense
giving vitamins to people but one of the
arguments that I would like to make is
biofortification is targeted to rural
small holder farmers it's sustainable
and it's renewable but these three other
approaches should be complementary to
biofortification because there is no
single panacea that can be used to
overcome nutritional deficiencies and
our growing world population
one of the major traits or phenotypes
will be focused on in my lab is
pro-vitamin a and if you look at the
global prevalence of vitamin A
deficiency in the world and see the map
here of sub-saharan Africa and that
overlays quite well with in terms of
caloric intake of maize daily calories
and also in these sub-saharan Africa
countries people are subsisting on a lot
of other crops such as cassava which are
in a sense low in vitamin content as
well and the impact of this there are 7
million pregnant women 127 million
preschool age children that are vitamin
A deficient in the world and the
consequence also vitamin A deficiency
causes 600,000 early childhood deaths
blindness and 500,000 children each year
and all of this is preventable through
improved nutritional food consumption
and so when breeding any crop the first
question you must ask yourself is there
natural variation for this particular
phenotype and in maize there is so if we
were just looking at the gradient of
yellow or light yellow to dark orange
kernel color phenotypes in a world's
collection of temperate and tropical
maize throughout the world if you look
at the total carotenoid profile in the
maize grain beta carotene which has the
highest Pro vitamin A activity only
accounts for 6% of all those carotenoids
so now once you highlight that when
we're talking about carotenoids and
maize are mostly found in the endosperm
and when you break out that 6% slice
here on average 1.7 microgram per gram
are found in these maize lines so that
is not very much and harvest Plus which
is very much focused on biofortification
of our important food crops as worked
with human nutritionists and they're
highly recommend and tenfold increase as
a pair - like the average there in terms
of this as a set breeding target and
this is a breeding target that people
have been trying to reach and some
breeding programs have actually
surpassed at this point in time
we also work on vitamin E in my lab as
well and in this case I would kind of
define vitamin e's more as an
insufficiency and when you look at
reports of insufficiency in the world
that would be in countries such as
Brazil the u.s. Tunisia South Africa but
in the u.s. about 26 or 41 percent of
individuals have plasma alpha-tocopherol
content in their plasma that is at a
level that increases their risk for
cardiovascular disease and so although
few reports exist for other developing
nations it is thought of that these
concentrations are probably even lower
and more widespread and thinking about
vitamin E and moreso alpha-tocopherol
which has highest vitamin E activity in
the human body and also animals we see
here of all the tobik Romanovs found in
maize grain here we have alpha
tocopherol in this shaded blue color
right here and that accounts for about
11% and almost all of that alpha
tocopherol is found in the embryo of
maize grain and here we have a higher
average as it compared to beta carotene
8.19 and if we do the calculations and
working with human nutritionists this is
approximately close to an a five-fold
increase that we would have to have as a
breeding target on average and so when
we look at where we were when we began
this one project about in 2010 the the
first take-home here is a lot of these
compounds are all derived from a shared
biosynthetic pathways such as like a
traumatic amino acid pathway and a p gdp
passed away here so here we have h GA
which is coming off and being used as a
head group and the final DP which is
important for the tail group and these
through the chemical action of the
enzymes themself give rise to all the
chemical variation for
criminals in maize grain and these two
jeans right here BT e1 and BTE four had
been we in our lab had been found to be
underlying large effect qtls and for the
carotenoid traits here we see the two
genes like e and critter b1 which have
been published on previously in 2008 and
2010 out of the work here at Cornell and
Ed's lab and these two genes himself
have been used in the sim and harvest
plus breeding program to develop orange
high pro-vitamin a maze so that seems to
work very well but these particular
genes them themselves are only capturing
just a snapshot of the variation in in
the maize germ plasm pool so what we're
trying to now do here is use large
populations to try to map the locations
of other qtls genes and in the maze
genome and here we have hapmap version 1
and version 2 that have been genotype
and impudent projected in the maze name
population here and working with our
colleagues at msu and dr. Dean della
pennis lab
we've run HPLC and almost 20,000 HPLC
runs to quantify the carotenoid content
and composition and the same for took a
criminal vitamin e took a chrome and all
content and composition and expression
profiling has also been performed as
well on all of the like 26 NAMM parents
and also at 6th of stages post
pollination times 40,000 genes so in a
sense we want to really understand which
genes are turned off over the the mental
program of the kernel itself and to also
put the QTL on a time axis
and to carry out this this research in
animation and population what we first
do is what is referred to as a joint
linkage analysis and here we're
identifying the qtls
in the maze genome so you can think of
the maze name population as a map within
a map and here we're just using the
recent recombination that has happened
in the construction of the maze dam
population so in a sense we're just
identifying the chromosomal segments in
the genome that have that QTL and with
the jiwa switch now we're using a higher
quantity of snips here what renowned you
is using is the ancient recombination
and so this is the through the
evolutionary history of maze and you can
see the LD blocks compared to the recent
recombination map are much smaller so
this is where we're going to receive the
higher resolution for trying to finally
map and hopefully I identified the
causal genes that are controlling
variation for these important
nutritional grain trades and so in our
work what we've found here if you just
focus on the carotenoid traits first we
found that essentially 10 a priori
pathway and two novel genes mostly
underlie the natural variation for these
carotenoid traits in maize grain and
just to walk you through this dxs two
and three so these two genes were
involved in the parental tail synthesis
three genes upstream of the pathway
branch point right here psy one PDS one
in mutants right here and then these
four genes within the core pathway right
here like e blue one crit RB 1 and zip 1
and we reconfirmed like II and crit RB 1
which had been previously used in the
Senate harvest plus breeding program and
we also identified a carotenoid cleavage
enzyme which essentially is turning over
the in the carotenoid compounds and
chewing them up which is definitely not
what you want
and so when we dissect this even further
essentially about six a priority pathway
genes that are what we refer to as
expression QTL or explaining the
majority of the phenotypic variation for
for these traits and this is like e psy
one Zepp one CCD one DX s two in critter
b1 and in a sense these variants that
are associating with the phenotype are
our cysts and it's explaining the the
fact that there are expression QTL and
then the other genes that were hid do
not appear to be expression QTL so
perhaps that the the actual snips or the
cause of variants are changing the
activity of the enzyme itself that would
be like loot one DHS three a mutants and
PDS one and then the two novel genes
that we hit here one is an
uncharacterrized protein so you can
obviously just hypothesize what you
think it may be because it's
uncharacterized that's a great thing
about candidate genes in this context
and then the other one was a mid
transcription factor i would like to
point out that these two novel genes
here though were only associated with
total carotenoids
so with this maze named population of
5,000 recombinant inbred lines we were
able to really dissect down to the gene
level the largest effect QTL and when
you focus on this orange part so this is
the amount of like phenotypic variants
explained by a priority genes the grey
part is the amount explained by those
two genes that are novel and these are
on unresolved low sigh in a sense we
don't really know what those causal
genes are so by by seeing this you could
probably be saying well why do you have
to use the maze name population you
could have just done my candidate gene
approach what we didn't realize at the
time is that be known a priori kanda
genes would explain the majority of the
variation but for the genes that are
unresolved they explain about one person
cent or less of the variation and in
those regions of the maze genome there
aren't any a priority candidate genes so
those are things that we can certainly
follow up on but in a breeding context
they don't explain that much of the
variation and so now when you think
about breeding for beta carotene which
is the compound that has the highest
robot M&A activity found in the maize
grain these five genes here are the ones
that you would focus on the XS - psy one
like II and crit RB one and so you can
think of very much as this is just
reduced to a combinatorial breeding
approach and you're just running to
figure out the best allelic combination
to put together in your breeding program
so that you can calibrate the
composition and the total or the type of
carotenoid phenotype in your grain and
just these two two genes that we have
just talked about previously they've
been used and the harvest loss breeding
program they have been used to
re-release new hybrids in in Zambia and
this is an outgrowth of the orange hyper
about him in a maze and some some work
that was published about five years ago
showed that this orange hi-pro vitamin A
maize was as effective as providing
vitamins to Zambian children that had
low levels of vitamin A so it isn't just
that we were able to select on the genes
himself but what was shown by
nutritionist is that this product this
orange high pro vitamin a is as
effective as giving vitamins to the
children so I think this is one of the
rare cases where you work closely with
like the the growers and the avarice
population and you understand their
their needs and that's something that
harvest Plus does very well so that
after maybe eight to ten years of
developing a new hybrid or a new emperor
line people will actually use it
and some of the work now that we're
focused on is really on deployment of
these genes and then understanding how
well these hybrids are performing under
heat and drought stress and Christiana
for my PhD and my my lab worked for a
year in Zimbabwe with CIMMYT and here is
one of the field days that they had
where they were showing to to the public
these new very least orange hyper
vitamin A and breadlines hybrids and
then showing you know people how they
look after being cooked and then they
could like taste them as well here's an
image from her her drought test that she
was doing and we're about 300 hybrids
that were bred to be high in pro by men
a were tested under heat and drought
stress and we we have all this seed now
in our cold chamber will be analyzing it
as well to see how the composition of
that grain was perturbed over time from
from the heat and drought stress so
moving on now to vitamin E this is a
nice contrast here because here we found
that a priori eight that is a priori
pathway genes and then six novels genes
explained about sixty percent of that
natural variation for it took a criminal
traits in maize grain and here we have
dia XS 2 DX s 3 and if you recall those
were hit four carotenoids as well so the
re d H 2h p BD 1 SDS bt e 3h g d 1b d 3
B&B t e4 so the majority of the
phenotypic variation though is explained
by a priori genes for tocotrienols and
so for trying all traits have high
antioxidant capacity and that would be
such as the the gene hdgt 1 but we found
that novel genes mostly controlling the
variation for tick off roles so if you
look down in this part of the table here
so this would be like these snare
proteins the fibrillin this
transporation protein and PhD gene here
and working with dean Dilip in Isla
in a rabid OPS's there I say we've been
able to confirm that some of these genes
do have a contribution to this pathway
so that's really nice because we've been
able to take the gene from maze put it
in a line of rabid ops instead no longer
has this gene functional to show the
confirmation and recapitulation of the
phenotype the two genes that I would
like to focus more on now are the proto
chlorophyll I'd read duct aces pour one
in pour two and this was a real surprise
to us that we found these genes to have
a very large effect in these two genes
they're homeo logs in the maize genome
explained almost all of the variants for
a total to cough Rawls that we found so
why this is intriguing is because these
two genes are involved in the
chlorophyll biosynthetic pathway so here
we have protoporphyrin a the poor gene
is doing a reducing reaction here then
we have the chlorophyll ID a which lacks
the final tail then that's added through
the GG ear geranyl journal and then we
have the chlorophyll a and B right here
and so this is where we begin to
hypothesize what may be going on we did
analyze embryo and the India sperm of
these developing maize kernels and we
found trace amounts of chlorophylls
other present in the maize embryo just
remind you the maize grain is non green
non-photosynthetic so why is chlorophyll
in it okay and so when you look here
this is days after pollination here on
a's x-axis sixteen to thirty six days
after pollination and this is from the
embryos and this is average across the
25 NAMP errants here and on the y-axis
is the long concentration of each of
these compounds so calls here you can
see is increasing over time but you do
actually see chlorophyll a here or
Philby
and then a precursor of chlorophyll lied
a and this would be more related to a
degradation product without the
magnesium pheophytin a and this is just
a remind you what that the final group
here is important for defining
chlorophyll a versus chlorophyll I'd a
right here but when you think about the
amount of chlorophyll that's found in
the embryo versus the leave the
chlorophyll took off for all molar ratio
is one to eight hundred in the embryo
thus we we feel that chlorophyll
degradation is not sufficient as a
source of fight all to generate it took
off roles in the developing embryo of
maize grain so what we think is
happening here is actually a cycle so we
we hypothesize that the fight all forty
corals and embryos most likely provided
through the floor filled biosynthetic
pathway so first just to draw your
attention to this plot here this is days
after pollination again and on x-axis
and the correlation of each of these
different metabolites with the total
amount of tocopheryl here and here we
see a strong correlation over the
developmental time period for
chlorophyll a for also chlorophyll I'd a
and chlorophyll b but we need to not see
a strong correlation at all and in fact
it is very weak for pheophytin 8a so
this reaction right here involving these
pores is a strongly light dependent
reaction and so what we think is
happening here is that the final group
is somehow being cleaved from the
chlorophyll a and that it's being used
by p te v and the fight over e salvaging
pathway and that is what's leaving to
cough rawls and here if the degradation
of the fight all was very important and
very strong we would think and
hypothesize that the pheophytin a signal
here
be very strong but we're not seeing that
at all and so for this cycle to actually
happen
we have hypothesized that or at least
one or two more enzymes here to to cause
this cycle to actually turn and and we
have some leads and and we've cloned
genes now that we think are filling out
this pathway part right here one other
thing is that we have tested out in this
field in in the field season this year
and also last year since this is a
strong a light dependent reaction what
we did is after pollination yeah it was
about 5 to 10 days after pollination so
we have our pollination bag on the ear
we have these foil hats that we're
putting on the ear so no light can
penetrate the ear at all and then after
you know comes off October and the first
snowfall we go out there and harvest and
then we take off those foil hats we make
sure that there was no penetration of
light and then we analyzed the samples
with the HPLC and so what we found here
to test this hypothesis is we think if
it is an important reaction in involving
these poor genes that if you block out
the light then the amount of the copper
all should decrease as well and that's
what we saw in the first year and we're
just reconfirming this year as well and
so to to complement that we've also been
doing CRISPR of these two four genes as
well but as you would expect if you
CRISPR two important genes in a
chlorophyll biosynthetic pathway you
would expect for the crisp red plants to
be very pale and berry green so we are
treating these plants as they are our
own children and we're trying to ensure
that we actually get seed from them and
hopefully we'll be analyzing those by
HPLC as as well this coming spring so
that's that's our hypothesis that we're
trying to confirm now with the
chlorophyll cycle so the largest effect
QTL for the toca chrome and all pathway
has technically been resolved to the
gene level and could be deployed in
breeding programs but as you see here it
is still a fair amount of unresolved QTL
right near right now and this is what
we're following up and on our PG RP
pathway grant right now and this is work
is being carried out by d wu and j wu li
and in our lab right now and mat Shu has
been talking about this for about the
the past four years we are trying to
leverage all of our investment in
understanding the genetic architecture
of carotenoids and tokomon also
providing a vitamin E and important
Sante bills lutein is the assassin to
improve your sweet corn I know it's like
winter and there's snow on the ground
think about eating more highly
nutritious or and of course covered in
butter and in the coming summers so now
we we have done close to about two 200
crosses and and we now have identified
in important genes that are also key
players such as like e-trade R b1 h TG t
1 V T you want to be to you for and when
you think about you can have these
important haplotypes fixed as your
cofactors and your GS models and then
you have can have the poly gene effect
capturing that residual variance and in
fact the prediction ability for these
phenotypes can be quite high and in our
breeding population so I in fact do have
a breeding program even though it's hard
to believe some sometimes when I find
time we're actually out in the field and
it's it can be some very tasty
phenotyping if you ever want to come
join us in terms of quality traits and
so now I'm gonna begin to switch gears
to some of the high throughput
phenotyping work that we've also been
doing in my lab over the past 10 years
and this was driven out by having some
early discussions when I was doing my
PhD here with with John Luke when we
were I was at still trying to figure out
what is genomic selection so I would
chat with John Luke he would be like
it's you know your genotype and
phenotype them you know a population
this training population you train a a
GS model and
ideally you genotype your breeding
material and try to predict what those
phenotypes actually are but even though
you're doing that you still need highly
accurate phenotypes and you still have
to be doing phenotypes as you retrain
the models after say every three or four
cycles as the allele frequencies are
changing and why I began working on this
because in Arizona I was very focused on
trying to improve the heat and drought
stress tolerance of cotton and as as
with new nutrition I think about
children and the the body mints they're
not receiving but in this case during
the early part of 2010 through 2012
there have been repeated droughts and
including in Texas here in in 2012 we're
a humble cotton farmer can just lose
their in entire crop from drought and so
what I quickly began realizing is we
needed a very effective way to do
Hydrabad phenotyping for heat and
drought tolerance in in the field and
how we began doing this when I was
working at the USDA was having this high
clearance tractor right here to
phenotype canopy temperature in dbi
which is basically a vegetation index
doing like chlorophyll content if you
will
biomass and then height and then we were
testing this on a recombinant inbred
line population of cotton close to 100
recombinant lines we had also phenotype
agronomic traits at the end of the
season with a combine or cotton picker
going through the field and various
yield components fiber quality traits
and physiological leaf traits EPS Isak
acid and and the sizing acid
concentration was here at Cornell thanks
to Tim Sutter and we were doing all this
under drip irrigation so we can have a
highly managed stress environment and we
would calculate how long and how much of
the irrigation should be applied for
these two wet and dry regimes right here
and we were able to do this phenotyping
over the entire growing
season so say we would phenotype every
Thursday and then we would do at four
time points within that single day over
the whole growing season so in a sense
we really wanted to understand how is
this particular population responding to
the imposed heat and drought stress over
time from at flowering to at the end of
harvest when a a cotton picker would
drive through the field and quantify
yield and so what we were able to do
this is essentially paint the the genome
to see what QTL are turned on and off as
as a result from the dry stress though
wet well water controlled treatment and
on the x-axis year is the year so we did
this over three years 2010 2011 2012 and
this x-axis here is the position of long
two genomes each of these are a
chromosome and so would you can easily
see here in this very almost crazy
painting if you will is that you can see
the the time points when certain QTL are
turned on and how long that they're
turned on for and then you can kind of
see if they're turned on between years
and across years as as well and the the
red are alleles that are increasing the
canopy temperature and the blue are
alleles that are decreasing the canopy
temperature and this work was carried
out by a former postdoc here is now at
the University of Arizona as a new
professor so here we have a nice Canada
gene ABA
but this is a large genome ik interval
here but with a candidate gene you can
always hypothesize what may be happening
and why ABA may be important is in this
context because when we had mapped the
cotton leaf ABA content the key field
mapped to the same genomic location as
this QTL that was turned on very
strongly for canopy temperature why that
is important is as the stomata are open
transpiration is high and as ABA is
expressed in the leaf and becomes
through high concentration
actual stomata closed and transpiration
decreases so in effect this could very
much have some be somehow linked to
changes in the canopy temperature in
terms of variation in this cotton
recombinant inbred law in population but
that is just indirect phenotyping of a
trait such as really what you're trying
to get at is the amount of water in a
leaf so what we've been doing over the
past few years working with Wigan Lou
and my lab and fuschia John and a Brooks
lab is developing these nano sensors
that we call aqua dust to infiltrate
into the leaves to more directly
quantify water potential so how this is
working as these have these like small
floor for particles that are hooked on
to these particles and when you
infiltrate into the the actual leave
they will expand and contract based on
the leaf water potential so if the water
potential is very low that means the
plant the plant is undergoing stress and
so then you would have shrinkage of
these nano particles and then these fret
particles would be an to interact with
each other and then you would have a
high fluorescence signal and we also did
validation and we were showing here in
this curve so this is like water
potential from a pressure chamber it
you've also made me heard it referred to
as a pressure bomb so all this is an
actual work that you actually have to
leg cut the leaf off and put it into
pressure problems and quantify this but
on the y-axis here is a fret efficiency
of those particles and you see it's
following this line very well so what
this gave us confidence in telling us
that we are able to directly measure
leaf water potential in the leaf using
these nanoparticles and this is a
confocal image here showing the
distribution of these nanoparticles in
the leaf themself and you can see that
the Aqua dust is residing in the April
plastic region and really what it's
doing is providing a measure of the low
water potential in that leaf so this is
really I think one of the first steps to
really begin high throughput phenotyping
of water potential and it's direct
quantification of water potential so we
wouldn't have to do it through canopy
temperature we wouldn't have to do it
with the pressure bomb this is injecting
particles in the leaf so the next part
is going to be about biotic stress and
this is what happens when you hang out
with Rebecca Nelson you begin working on
northern leaf flight so as I've become
to learn and actually call these lesions
beautiful because when they're not
showing up in our field in a season if
it's not beautiful as we have found out
this past summer so the fungus that
causes these Brown product lesions these
these lesions can begin you know to grow
and coalesce over over time and
unfortunately NLB disease as actually be
beginning to increase over time since
since 2012 and it can be high as a 1.9
billion economic loss and that was the
case in 2015
considering US and Ontario so this is
really a disease on the rise and one of
the challenges here and the sliminess
work really began with Jesse Poland when
he was here as a PhD student at the same
time was is really how do you rapidly
visually assess it'll be a disease
presence or severity which is a
quantitative phenotype out in the field
and it often is very slow and imprecise
so here we have the case where this is
our NLB true positive this or in OB true
negative but even just trying to see
these lesions by eye
assuming you're able to find a positive
one is very slow as you walk through the
field and then quantitatively is also
very challenging when you're trying to
do severity which is in the sense
disease leaf area is here this is the
case of mean interrater radio bility
repeatability of only 0.76 so this is
like comparing the same repeater to
themselves going from say in week one or
I'm sorry week ten to week 12 and then
seeing how close their ratings relate
and then the inter-rater repeatability
is actually even lower so this is not
only slow but it is imprecise when
you're trying to do it quantitatively
for diseased looped area so the the idea
that we had and this is where hanging
out with computer sciences computer
scientists and engineers is very
sometimes intimidating to learn their
language and understand what they're
talking about
at first but as soon as you get out
you're your comfort zone and you realize
that they can do so much more to help
your research then I'm hanging out with
them all the time and having
conversations with them every week so
the idea was and and this is what a lot
of people will refer to as machine
learning deep learning and this is using
these C and in sand you can just think
about using a CNN this converting and
pixel into a logistic unit one zero
presence absence of a lesion and what
this essentially doing is where we're
applying these filters to detect
features and that's what is referred to
as a convolution and then the pooling is
really simplifying the layers you're
trying to convince this information to
allow more filters to be applied and
then you're extracting these multiple
layers of the non feature and then
almost like an ensemble classifier is
combining all these features to make a
prediction at the end either deletion is
present or it's not and so what we've
been doing and this has been carried out
by our wonderful pilot Nick has more in
the lab is using the UAVs to really
speed up the large-scale disease
detection in the field and here's one of
those UAV images right here of some
really nice lesions on on these plants
and working with Hans group at Columbia
University
Harvey Wu and Chad Deshawn and tear here
at Cornell we've been able to do highly
accurate and OB lesion detection here so
after we have our trained cnn's we've
been able to achieve an accuracy of
almost almost 98% with a holdout test so
we were actually able to detect these
lesions the presence
of absence of them very well out in the
field but we really want to do severity
we want to make Rebecca Nelson happy and
so this is what we've been trying to do
over the past two years is make her
happy and we're getting closer so the
the great people at Facebook have
developed what is called a mask regional
CNN short for mask our CNN so this is
what we began doing and this work is led
by Ethan Stewart in our lab and so you
can see a nice lab photo right here of
us all happy and smiley and then we can
run that mask our CNN here and then it's
running these classifiers so the idea
here is you're conducting object
detection by drawing these bounding
boxes around each class and then you're
doing like a segmentation algorithm on
each of these bounding boxes to classify
a pixel as as an object so what Ethan
has been doing is really trying to carry
this forward in into the plant world
from from the Facebook world and see
roots here we have an image of a
diseased lesion here and here is where
it's been outlined by a human being and
this is where the masks are CNN would
predict that there's one lesion here and
then drawing the area around that one
lesion and then the iou is the overlap
in that area so this one actually looks
fairly well but there are cases when it
does not look very well and this looks
like we have a piece of an anther or a
tassel here occluding this lesion right
here which is where a human drew it very
nicely here and drew a part of this
lesion here but as you see this piece of
attachable is kind of confounding the AI
so to overcome that we just need a
larger training set and Ethan may have
to drink more coffee
so after that so with the UAVs what
we've begun working now within an Ed's
group here is Cornell and it's trying to
really understand how you use robotics
for phenotyping and incorporate them
into clamp reading programs and this is
with rich Choudhary's group at a
university Illinois urbana-champaign and
this
on our Tara MEP project from funded by
the rpe
so the 10 was to develop this for
phenotyping biomass sorghum over over
time and so what we're now developing
with our lab is a comparative hapmap and
that's trying to integrate the
evolutionary histories of maize and
sorghum to improve the predictions of
these complex traits in sorghum and
Jonathan here is four here from one year
from Brazil what he's beginning to do is
develop these Bayesian models that can
use what is referred to as forward
training cross-validation where you can
say have a robot going through the field
but then you're incorporating these time
points early in the season as part of
your training set to try to predict a
phenotype at the end of the season
so in this case this is height and we're
using days after planting 30 and 45 days
to train the actual Bayesian model we're
using that information to predict height
at the end of the season and that as we
found been able to increase our
prediction accuracy so when you think
about a Hydrabad phenotyping approach
can you begin to corporate phenotypes
early in the season to improve your
accuracy so you can predict something
such as height or yield more accurately
at the end of the season so you can
think of this as saving time then you
would know early on what crosses to make
early in the season F prior to flowering
and as Jonathan has also shown at
certainly later weeks after planting
there isn't much changing in the rank
order of of those plants for height and
having a robot makes you very happy as I
have found and IDI would probably a test
to that as well so what we're really
beginning to think about and do here is
trying to integrate these unmanned
ground vehicles these unmanned aerial
vehicles to really tandem Li phenotype
and it'll be disease presence and
severity from the understory to the
canopy because I have now learned that
the N OB disease
starts at the understory and it works
its way up if you're seeing it from the
air it actually may be too late
so what we're now trying to work on is
do in sync phenotyping approach where
we're trying to integrate the
information from the ground rovers and
the UAV to really understand the rate of
disease Pro progression over the whole
growing season and with that in mind and
this is where hanging out with computer
scientists can can be very fun we're
really thinking about now a concept of a
software-defined farm where you're you
are using the TV white space and a
software called farm beats using that to
eventually do into in image processing
nearly in real time as you're collecting
you the UAV data or from the ground
rover to really understand how diseases
are breaking out and how you would
better manage your your crop and this is
under the umbrella of Sita and this is
with my colleague Hakeem and computer
science so this is kind of where we are
beginning to see and take hydrogen
phenotyping where it was once just
thought of maybe we would just focus on
one trait but it's really now beginning
to think how do we fully integrate this
in a breeding program but how do we
employ it so you also better manage our
crop at the farm level and how do we
sense and react at the same time because
then you can think about having like a
UAV or a a ground Weaver which the
highly concentrated candor serves of
like fungicide or a pesticide that can
have a variable application through the
field over time and that's where to have
that actually to be possible would
require something as a software-defined
farm
that there's a lot of people to thank
and funding agencies for the carotenoid
work would be at MSU and Purdue
University and here at Cornell with Ed's
group the like CNN disease work would be
hard to group at Columbia University Rob
focus group here at Cornell and for the
earth since that would be our Rover and
then the phenotyping early work was
involving colleagues at the University
Arizona and USDA a lark and
unfortunately I did not have enough time
to talk about the other 20 projects that
we have going on in the lab because I
didn't want this presentation to be just
one slide for each project but we're
also doing some I think some great work
and oat and cassava as well and other
projects and in maize but unfortunately
I just didn't have the time to go do a
fast forward through all those projects
I thank you very much no that's actually
something we looked at very early on and
so DX s2 and D X s3 are kind of the the
only shared I'll just call them
precursor genes and there isn't that
much pleiotropy as we like previously
thought one one thing and and harvest
plus is probably going to begin
hopefully breeding for this is that
since some of the tocotrienols are very
strong antioxidants that you can breed
for them at the same time to help
prevent the breakdown of pro-vitamin a
and in the maize brain and that has been
shown as sorghum transgenic ly by the
pioneer group but i actually think we
can do that through breeding in maize as
well great question
yes Susan I'm trying to process the idea
that chlorophyll indeed if I understood
it in the embryo yes correct
I'm just curious how light gets to the
embryo within the kernel on the cob
through the house and I and I've been
I'm sorry but must be obvious it's not
obvious it's there is a very low level
of light that can print it rate the husk
leaves we've we have found but how much
light is needed I don't think it
requires that not much but that is
something that we're trying to figure
out and follow up on so we we have also
done I guess the counter part of our
test you know how we had foil on the
cobs we've also had ears where we took
off almost all of the husk leaves and
our hypothesis is that the two controls
should go up even higher and that's well
I hope they have the answer to you in
like a couple months oh that's a good
question I do not know yeah that's a
great question
it's it's quite possible since it is
going through like pale green husk
leaves yeah that's that's very possible
yeah so okay so that's what I get for
bringing that up okay that's a great
question so what we're actually creating
here is a comparative hapmap and so you
can think about the diversity of sorghum
right pie right so what we're doing is
using a machine learning model where we
have all the different sorghum Popkin
parameters such as row you know other
recombination rates and you know other
genomic features but what we found is as
we look at the synthetic regions between
maize and sorghum where you say getting
pie and
gene expression from Mays as well we're
able to better predict the diversity
patterns of swaram using that
information so I think if this is the
case where you are able to harness the
scent in acree jhin's that are more
stable and shared and so the idea is
perhaps there'll be some of the shared
if you will control those complex trade
variation at the same time and we've
been playing around with this and maize
and rice for the control of say like
iron and zinc variation weave it's
actually kind of turning out to be very
cool and very powerful where we have
orthology between the two and then we're
like okay there's jia sit here do you
I'll sit here then we're able to kind of
tease that out by just having like rice
and in maize and so you can kind of
think of it as the same way when you're
using maize and sorghum as well
yeah other questions sorry Jen why I
can't hear ya sorry I I like have to
walk all the way ah yeah that's that's a
good question so the question was for
the NLB lesions can you distinguish them
from other abiotic stresses and and so
we've we've actually I guess taken the
easy route where we've just been
focusing on lesions but we know all
those lesions are just caused by the one
pathogen right i I think as we begin to
expand out and have this to be something
that's more transferable and more
valuable either thing about having the
test of when there's like multiple
diseases present and in the combination
of abiotic stress as well but the the
thing is though and the thing you have
to keep in mind at this present time the
humans are training the AIS so if the
human can't distinguish the two or two
three or the four then it's going to be
very hard to train to a is sure over
time as AI strain themself they may be
able to figure it out but we're not
quite there yet yeah good question
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu